[Musique]
joli pari du mois d'août on dirait même
que ceux qui restent sont aussi en
vacances
flânerie dans la tente de clients
problématique on dirait que tout le
monde est parti flânerie au bord des
toits vide comme on dit il n'ya plus un
chat l'ânerie ensommeillés sur les bancs
des squares c'est vraiment un pari en
vacances ceux qui ne sont pas partis se
retrouve quand même dans un univers tu
n'es pas celui des mois ordinaire il y à
de beaux voyages immobiles avec des
compagnies si charmante est aussi un
fidèle dame de pique ou reine blanche et
dans l'ombre des invalides on en voit
d'autres qui se crée une provence
d'occasions la carte postale d'un petit
copain apporte l'air du large juste ce
qu'il faut pour imaginer sur un bout de
trottoir les joies de la cua plane et du
ski nautique sans aquaplane essentiels
aux tic
tout de même il y en a qui ont découvert
la scène celle qui évoque la vézère
[Musique]
celles qui rappellent concarneau celle
qui ressemble à bandol
[Musique]
c'est aussi à cette date qui apparaît
une nouvelle espèce l'espèce des
célibataires provisoire confrérie
silencieuse dont les membres ont comme
signe de reconnaissance dans leur
restaurant un journal près de la ration
chaque matin le goût puissant de leur
fier indépendant sera conquise leur
monte à la tête devant les chaussures à
cirer et la vaisselle qui s'accumulent
ils sont ceux qui restent et ils vont
quelquefois regarder une fenêtre celle
du ministre des finances qui s'il n'en
reste qu'un ce sera sûrement celui là
[Musique]